to people around the world archbishop
desmond tutu was a champion of freedom
and the fight against racial segregation
in south africa
to others he was simply a husband father
and grandfather
many of the messages we received have
said
thank you for sharing him with the world
well it actually is a two-way street
because we shared him with the world
you shared part of the love you held for
him
with us
and so we
are thankful
among the speakers at st george's
cathedral michael newton who served as
tutu's deputy for many years
first let me say a few words to the
chief mourinho among us
my dear lia
marriages of our
church many times you wiped away the
tears of your husband
for as we all know
he cried very easily
and in the life of our country both past
and present
he had much to cry about
the service for many was deeply personal
much of the proceedings done according
to archbishop tutu's last wishes
a plain pine coffin adorned with the
symbols of the church while the
eucharist server centered around tutu's
anglican beliefs and spiritual
leadership his activism against global
oppression and as the leading voice
against apartheid laws in south africa
was to the fourth
archbishop desmond tutu
was without question a crusader in the
struggle for freedom
for justice
for equality and for peace
not only in south africa
the country of his birth
but around the world as well
while at times solemn the service also
celebrated the archbishop through his
favorite hymns and scriptures
his last moments at st george's
cathedral marked by a final blessing
archbishop desmond tutu was loved by
many but covert 19 restrictions limited
how they would have liked to pay their
final respects instead they participated
in services at smaller parishes across
the country
[Music]
clergy and bishops form a guard of honor
as a final goodbye to a remarkable man
simply known as the arch
he's ashes to be later interred at the
church he called home
family al jazeera cape town